so to make this filling we're going to
use this giant Apple just kidding we're
using just regular sized apples just 50
pounds of it
hey my name is Tui and welcome to making
it big the show where I turn your
favorite foods giant today I have my
friend Alvin visiting me and I think he
has a special challenge for me kind of
nervous but a little bit excited so
Alvin come on out yo yo hi welcome thank
you for having me I have something
special for you I'm kind of nervous look
I'm a big dude this is making it big I'm
gonna do it nice and slow McDonald's
apple pie I'm already loving this
challenge I have a few questions for you
though how big exactly I'm talking big
big baby big baby big yeah yeah I think
you can make it happen does it have to
look exactly like this I would think
that you have to nail the Box the box is
the key to my Nostalgia and then how
about these these little like design on
it the lattice the lattice the lattice
is pretty huge okay fine you know what
it is too is we need to know that's an
apple pie I guess it's time for me to
make my version of the McDonald's apple
pie boom so first things first I need to
start on the pie dough and this is five
pounds of flour right into the bowl then
I'm going to add some sugar and salt
taking my little whisk whisking this all
together this is my favorite part of
making pie dough is the butter I have
two pounds of butter in here so that
means two pounds of
deliciousness and then I'm going to coat
the butter all of this flour together
and then now I'm taking this pastry
blender AKA my Wolverine tool to really
Mash in the butter and the flour
together I just need it to get into the
consistency of wet sand so when I think
about fast food apple pie I always think
that it's a luxury because growing up
just ordering desserts in general was a
luxury as soon as I was able to make my
own money
it was apple pie all day every day I'm
very happy with my dough I'm going to
add in some ice into this water because
I want it to be ice cold and this right
here is the secret ingredient apple
cider vinegar this is what's going to
make my high crust really flaky I don't
like flaky people but I love flaky pie
so and then I'm going to add three cups
of this water into my pie dough
but no ice goes in the water
oh my God there's ice there's ice
oh that's much better look at me using
my big brain I'm gonna take my spatula
and just fold it in and we are making a
total of two batches because we need one
dough for the bottom and then one dough
to cover the top now I'm gonna go in
with my hand and just kind of mold it
making pie dough is so tricky because it
seems very easy but it's not baking in
general seems like yeah but it's not
this is taking everything in me to not
need it but you can't need pie dough
because it'll start to develop gluten
and that won't give you a flaky crust
and we want a flaky crust I'm very happy
with how this came together I'm gonna
lay down some Saran Wrap and now I bring
this bad boy over oh my God
I'm going to shape this into a big
rectangle so it's easier for me to roll
it out later I'm really happy with this
shape and I'm gonna just wrap this up
all right so this is my first one I'm
going to make one more and then let them
both rest for an hour
so to make this filling we're going to
use this giant Apple just kidding we're
using just regular sized apples just 50
pounds of it in order to make a giant
apple pie I have to peel and chop a lot
of apples I have a lot of work so I'm
gonna go right into it this is only
therapeutic for like two three apples
and then everything just kind of turns
into a blur so the first time I had a
fast food apple pie was when I was in
culinary school actually it was actually
Perfection and now I have this handy
dandy apple cutter and apple core I'm
just gonna go ahead and go for it this
is my first time using this
oh I like this let's keep healing I'm
using both green and red apples because
the green apple holds up really well
when it's cooking but it's a little bit
tart so I'm mixing it with the red so
it's a nice balance
I don't know if you have to be that
violent but I gotta be it looks like I
still have a lot of work to do so I'll
check back in in about like an hour and
ah 50 pounds of peeled and cut apples
later I'm here and now I'm going to pour
some lemon juice right over the top of
this to prevent Browning and to also cut
the sweetness from the apples then I'm
gonna go over here adding some
cornstarch to a bowl along with some
sugar this is nine cups of sugar some
salt and some cinnamon and this will be
my cinnamon sugar mixture that will go
right into the apples and so I'm gonna
mix this together with my hands so I
could feel that the apples are really
gripping onto the cinnamon sugar this is
a bit overwhelming because this is a lot
of apples wait I kind of like this
instead of like playing with slime I
feel like this should be the new wave oh
there you
there's a lot of liquid down here at the
bottom of the bowl and I'm really happy
about that because when I cook it down
that's going to give it that like syrupy
it's all going to look at my nails
poking through
okay so these are ready I'm gonna take
them to the stove and cook them
well this is the biggest pan that I
could find and I have all five burners
on I'm just gonna add in two sticks of
butter
yum so the Butter's melted now I have to
add the apples but I'm probably gonna
have to phone a friend because I can't
carry that and put it in at the same
time
oh well this is only half of the batch
because I don't want to overcrowd the
pan I kind of want to take a bath in
this
so apparently McDonald's apple pie was
the first dessert to be added to their
menu in
1968. that's older than my mom so the
original apple pie was fried instead of
baked like how it is today I would
prefer it fried can they bring that back
McDonald's uses a variety of six
different American grown apples Fuji
Gala Golden Delicious Ida Red Jonah gold
and Rome apples The Filling is done and
it looks so good it smells even better
by the way I'm gonna need some help
carrying this
it's over there
here we go I'm hungry
so good this is only one batch I have
another batch to cook down after that
I'm gonna cool them and put them in the
fridge now it's time to roll out my
dough I have like roughly 20 pounds of
dough right here both for the bottom and
for the top I'm Gonna Roll the bottom
out to the size of this sheet pan right
here so I'm dusting my Surface and my
rolling pin with flour just so my dough
doesn't stick oh let's get my let's get
one out I feel like I'm unwrapping a
present it is a present actually that I
made for myself regular pie dough is
already difficult to roll out as is like
just regular size but this is a whole
block
[Music]
I feel like this is going nowhere this
pie is definitely going to hit after
this workout Alvin better like this pie
or else so this part is actually not
only difficult because it's 10 pounds of
pie dough but I have to make sure that
it stays cold so the butter doesn't melt
I'm gonna flip it over again just so the
butter doesn't get warm and about 10
minutes later I am here with a full
sheet pan size of pie dough I think I am
ready to transport this into the tray
and I do have a special little thing I
want to introduce to you guys this is
called a pan extender and you basically
put it in the baking tray and this is
going to support the pie filling I'm
Gonna Roll this dough up my heart is
beating so fast and
okay
we're in now I'm just kind of just
pinching the dough to the edge just so
it can stay up so the hardest part about
making pie is the temperature you have
to keep it at a cold temperature so the
butter can stay put if the butter starts
to melt then the whole pie dough starts
to kind of fall apart and then in the
oven it falls apart gets soggy and then
you get a soggy pie and we don't want a
soggy pie we want a nice and Flaky pie
this is all nice and molded now I have
to put all of this filling into the pie
and I gotta move fast
this is so much apple if you've ever
wanted to see what 50 pounds of pie
filling looks like this right here then
I'm gonna fold this in and the egg wash
is basically an adhesive for the top
dough to stick okay
this is so difficult I'm gonna trim off
some extra pie dough on the side right
here so it's easier for me to tuck it
and the reason why I'm tucking it is
because we are making sure that it's
nice and sealed so the filling doesn't
spill out whoever said it's as easy as
pie they're lying they've never made pie
before this is pretty warm so I'm gonna
pop this in the freezer so I can cut out
the little design on top so I made a
special little stencil that I'm going to
use to cut the top of the pie I'm gonna
lay my stencil down here I have my
paring knife and my ruler I'm ready
let's go I'm feeling kind of nervous but
the ruler is giving me a lot of
confidence oop it moved okay and I gotta
move fast because this is nice and cold
right now and I don't want it to melt oh
that looks so good this stencil was such
a good idea because this would have been
a mess with no stencil
[Music]
gouache so it can look nice and golden
and then I'm going to sprinkle on some
turbinado sugar this is to add some
texture to the pie and also visually it
looks really really pretty into the oven
this goes I hope that it works out
I need someone to help me please
oh
wow okay
so this is actually 70 pounds because
it's 50 pounds of filling by itself and
then we have to account for the dough
and that's another 20 pounds so 70
pounds of pie and this big baby is going
to stay in here for four hours good luck
I'll see you in four hours all right so
the pie is done the box is also done I'm
really really excited for Alvin to see
this so Alvin please come on out
[Music]
yo what
what
I can't believe this is happening what's
your rating on the box 10 out of 10. who
did how do you do that do you want to do
the honors of pulling the pie out of the
box
oh whoa no way
wow that is legit an apple pie look at
the caramel it's perfect how many pounds
do you think this is just by opening it
it felt like it was like a 50 pound
Behemoth it's actually 70 pounds 70
pounds you can't even travel with that
this is beyond what I was expecting I
can't believe you can make anything this
big let's cut right into this baby look
it's hilarious all right I'm gonna do
one Big Slice
look at that that is a real apple pie
cheers
hmm that's perfect I'm very impressed
with myself this is crazy flavor is
magnified 10 times I don't think I can
eat the entire thing but I can give it a
damn real good try well this has been
such a fun project to work on thank you
for the challenge of course I can say
that I have made a 70 pound pie now and
it was delicious so in the comments
below let us know what we should make
next see you next time
[Music]
please
foreign